I revise my opinion of Megan I've also  heard from a very good source but it was  Harry who did more of the screaming and  yelling at staff when they were working  was and it was Megan who had to calm him  down this is completely new this is a  scoop I haven't told anyone about this  um so I think that she is much calmer  more conciliary and I think is that a  part that Harry has lived with their  sort of bitterness and and anger  um ever since his mother's death and he  hasn't been able to get rid of it  because um that I mean everything is  done with Megan what the Netflix thing  was  it was pretty harmless and it was all  sort of  um it was like home and garden  yeah very Californian but this is this  is bile stuff you know this is  hatred fueled stuff and I I don't think  it's coming from Megan at